- I think one of the interesting
things to observe is in
the past couple years, since
Covid really, a lot of people,
and this, I don't wanna
tell tales on my husband,
but my husband is
included in this category,
didn't believe that some of
this radical gender ideology
was in their local
public school, right?
Like you believed that
it was in California.
You might've believed
it was in New York.
You believed in an isolated
incident that you read on the
news here or there,
but you didn't believe
that it was everywhere,
that it could be in
your own neighborhood,
in front of your own child.
And I think parents have really
been awakened to the fact
that this capture of our
education system is complete.
This capture of our education
institution is total,
and that your child will
not be able to avoid it.
You can't opt them out of
social emotional learning.
It's too integrated into
everything about schools,
and social emotional learning,
a lot of parents
know what this is,
and they find it
to be questionable.
I talk about this
in my book because
social emotional
learning is another name
for the critical consciousness
that Paulo Freire,
the Brazilian Marxist,
wanted every child to
be brainwashed with.
It's disguised as,
"Oh, this is how we
teach children values.
This is how we
teach them morals.
This is how we teach them
to behave in a manner
that reflects right and wrong."
But we should all be asking,
"Well, what is your
definition of right and wrong?
What is your
definition of a value?"
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is the
host of "The Liz Wheeler Show,"
as well as the author of the
new book, "Hide Your Children:
Exposing The Marxists Behind
The Attack On America's Kids."
Liz Wheeler, welcome back
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hi, Dave, thanks
for having me.
- Liz, I think, if
I'm not mistaken,
this is your first
solo appearance on
"The Rubin Report."
You've been on like a
thousand panel shows,
but is this our
first one-on-one?
- It is, it is.
It doesn't seem
like the first time
because I'm so often on
your Friday show, but yes,
this is basically what it's
like when you and I hang out.
- Yeah, we shall see.
We shall see, a lot
of pressure, sister.
(Liz laughs)
Alright, you, just real
briefly, most of my audience,
of course, knows you,
but for the people
that do not know you,
you wanna give a a minute
recap of who Liz Wheeler is
and why it is that she's
trying to save our kids
from the Marxists?
- Yes, indeed.
I'm Liz Wheeler, I host
"The Liz Wheeler Show."
You can subscribe on Apple
Podcasts or wherever you watch
or listen to your pods.
- Podcast, podcast pro.
- I'm a political commentator,
I'm, yes, thank you,
thank you.
Maybe not YouTube.
Maybe head over to Rumble
if you value free speech,
because we talk about a lot
of topics that are not allowed
on YouTube, but what I'm
most dedicated to, I'm a mom.
I'm dedicated to
preserving this country,
this great country of
ours for my family,
for my two-and-a-half
year old daughter.
I see what's happening
before our very eyes.
I see the capture
of our institutions.
I see the degradation of the
fabric of ordered society,
and I don't want
that for my daughter.
The best part of this country
is it gives us the opportunity
to live virtuously,
to worship the God that we want,
to say what we want,
to live our lives according to
the tenets of our viewpoints.
And if we don't stop the
assault against those things,
then we're not going to have
the country that we have.
So we talk about everything
from Covid to transgenderism
to election integrity, to
the administrative state,
really pushing aside the
establishment Republicanism
that has actually led
us to where we are
and taking a more
based view of reality
in trying to solve the
crisis that we're facing.
- When did you realize
the level of the craziness
that we were fighting,
meaning something that
was beyond just, oh,
we're arguing about tax breaks
and we're arguing about,
you know, little
this and that issues,
but sort of the big cultural
stuff that, of course,
leads to all the
stuff related to kids?
- Yeah, that's a good question.
I'd like to think, and then
maybe this is too flattering,
it's too self-flattering,
I'd like to think I've been
based for a long time because
the way that I got into
politics and got into political
commentary was kind
of by accident.
I, in late high
school, was diagnosed
with a serious
autoimmune disease and
I spent a lot of time,
well, being sick with that
and recovering from that.
And during that period
of time, you know,
when you're sick,
you're kind of bored.
There's not a lot that
you can do physically.
So I started reading a lot of
books and getting involved.
This was like at the very
beginning of political Twitter,
getting involved in political
discussions on Twitter.
Just that was one
of my interests.
I liked sort of the adrenaline
that went with politics,
but I also at the same time,
given what I was
dealing with personally,
came to a realization that
these so-called institutions
that we trust,
the quote unquote experts
aren't always dedicated
to being an expert
in their field.
They're not always
dedicated to science.
For example, there was no
pharmaceutical solution
to the autoimmune disease
that, you know, I still manage,
I still deal with.
And what does Big Pharma do?
They just kinda brush
you to the side.
They aren't
interested in saying,
"Well, maybe if you manage
your diet differently,
maybe if there's some kind
of natural supplements
or something that you
can do alternatively
that this would help you have
more chance of
living a normal life.
They don't give
any of that advice.
They're only interested
in profiteering off of
people's problems.
So I think that I was,
for better or for worse,
red-pilled at a
relatively early age
because I saw that the only
reason that I was able to
actually pursue those
alternative means to health
was because my dad is
a small business owner
and he used the money that
he saved to pay out of pocket
for these alternative
treatments,
whereas if we were
in a socialist nation
and he wasn't free to enjoy
the fruits of his labor,
if we had a socialized
healthcare system,
I wouldn't have been
able to do that.
So I think I was red-pilled
and kind of cynical
about institutions
from the beginning.
And then once you realize
that that's the case
in one institution,
you see it happening in the
other institutions as well.
- And isn't that ironic
because some of the positions
you were talking about being,
you know, sort of leery
of, say Big Pharma,
those would've been thought
of as lefty positions
say 15-years ago.
- Yes.
- And now, especially
since Covid,
that has just completely
flipped on us.
- It's so funny because for
the majority of my adult life,
I'm 34, and for the
majority of my adult life,
I've lived in two
different worlds.
I live in the, I would say,
very conservative world
in politics.
And then I live with a
bunch of, I live in a world,
not literally, not
like a commune,
but with a bunch of crunchy
leftists who also go to the
chiropractor and also
try to eat plant-based.
And these people are
generally like really woo-woo,
hippie-dippy, crunchy people,
and they're leftists in their
politics for whatever reason.
But now it is funny.
It's even like
questioning things like
questioning vaccines.
That was always a
leftist position until
the Covid vaccine.
- [David] Right.
= And now the right
has adopted that.
It's funny to be in my position
where I've always been on
the line of conservative
politics, but leftist,
if you will, health views.
Because now it's like,
well, yes, join the club.
- Right. You were
also much like me,
you were in Cali
for Covid, you fled-
- Yes.
- California.
You did not make it to
the free state of Florida.
You went elsewhere.
(Liz laughs)
But you wanna talk about
how you were based in Cali
during a time of Covid?
- Yes, yes, I will.
And by the way, for everyone
watching and listening to this,
this is an ongoing,
this is bullying from Dave
to get me to come to Florida,
which I appreciate,
I appreciate,
although the humidity
might be a little high.
I love California.
Here's the thing, I
don't hate California
with this visceral rage
that a lot of people
feel towards it.
I think California is paradise.
I think there's a reason that
historically the Golden State
was the land of opportunity.
This is where you
would go, California,
to seek your fortune, really,
to find the American dream.
And it actually breaks my heart
to see what's happening in
California, because California
is still paradise in a sense.
It's beautiful, there's
so many resources.
It's like nowhere else
in the United States.
My heart is in California,
and it really is just crushing
to see what leftist politics
do to a land that is so
beautiful and so prosperous
and somewhere that it used to be
everyone desired to move to.
But with the open border and
with Gavin Newsom at the helm
with his technocratic
dictatorship in California,
with his dedication to quote
unquote climate change,
with cracking down
on free speech.
They have a law right now
that they're trying to pass.
It's a bill, I suppose,
that they're trying to pass
into law that would actually
define parents who declined
to put their children
on a gender-affirming,
quote unquote,
gender-affirming model
as child abusers.
You can't raise a family
in a climate like that,
that you risk losing your child,
the thing around which
your entire life revolves.
I mean, we are fighting in
politics, Dave, you and I,
because we want what's
best for our children.
It's not even about
us, we're adults.
We're halfway through
our lives already.
This is about what's
best for our families.
And you can't raise a
family in that circumstance.
You have to leave.
And it makes me really sad
because I didn't want to leave.
- It's so interesting
'cause for me, you know,
as a relatively new father,
like when that thing was
being passed in Cali,
which passed the legislature
by the way, right?
I mean, it's passed already.
- I think so, yeah.
- Now it's about
divorced families,
but they're gonna
expand it obviously.
I kept saying on the show,
it's like, "You must leave now
if you're a parent because
you're sending your kids
to schools where they will be
brainwashed into this stuff.
And you don't wanna be there
that day when they come
knocking at your door,
and, you know, 'We're calling
your daughter a boy's name,
and if you don't accept
it, we're taking the kid.'"
But it's real.
- Yeah, it's real.
And this is what I
write in my book.
I mean, the left is
actually waging a deliberate
and relentless assault
on our children.
This is not hyperbole,
this is not bombastic.
This has been going on
for the last century,
for a century the
left has attempted to
re-engineer society.
They've actually captured
and co-opted four of the five
foundational cultural
institutions in our nation,
the media and religion
and education and law.
And they've just about
destroyed the family as well.
There's one element that
is remaining of the family
and that is children.
And the left now has their
sights set on our children.
And meanwhile, while all
of this was happening,
what were Conservatives doing?
We were complacent.
We were blind to this.
We were blithely unaware
as this was happening.
And now we face
what we're facing.
We face a literal
assault on our children.
And so, in the book,
I name the names of
the people behind,
not only the capture
of these institutions,
but behind the attack
on America's kids.
If we don't acknowledge the
reality of the political enemy
that we're facing, we'll lose.
We will not win.
And it's not just a matter
of fighting for the sake
of children's individual souls.
If the left successfully
captures children,
our nation is done.
- So one thing that I
thought was interesting
in terms of the title is
that you said Marxists,
you didn't say wokesters,
you didn't say communists or
socialists, you said Marxists.
I wonder what was
your thinking on that?
Do you wanna define it clearly
and maybe contrast it to some
of those other terms because
everyone's sort of using them
interchangeably these days?
- It is, and it's
actually interesting
because when I started
writing this book,
I wasn't looking for Marxist.
It wasn't a fishing expedition.
I acknowledged what almost
every person in our country has
acknowledged that there
is this sustained assault
on our children from all
of these different angles.
And I thought, "Why, why now?
Why in this coordinated way?"
And it turns out the answer
to that question isn't a why.
It's a who.
Who is behind this and
why are they doing that?
And it turned out that there
was a pattern of ideology
behind each of these assaults.
So ,for example, what I
found is there is a Marxist
by the name of Antonio Gramsci,
who essentially brought back
from the dead original Marxism.
He revived it and turned it
into 21st century Marxism.
And he twisted it from
purely economic Marxism like,
"Oh, the working
class is gonna revolt
against the ruling class."
He turned it into,
"Well, wait a second,
the working class
isn't going to revolt
against the ruling
class if they rely on
the cultural institutions
of the working class."
So he said, "Before we stage
an economic revolution,
we have to stage a
cultural revolution.
We have to go after these
five major foundational,
civil institutions, the media,
education, religion, the law,
and the family."
And what we are seeing now,
it's so interesting, Dave,
what we're seeing
right now is not new.
It's not a new idea.
It's not a new ideology,
it's not a new enemy.
It's actually sometimes
hundreds of years old.
It's just been repurposed
for this moment.
It's why I say if we don't
acknowledge what we're facing,
we're not gonna fight
well against it.
But once you see who's
behind the assault
on each of these
institutions, I mean,
you can certainly put a stop
to it because you can simply
thwart their strategy,
which these old Marxists lay
out maybe even more clearly
than the new leftists do today.
- Do you make any meaningful
distinction between
some of those terms woke,
Marxist, communist, socialist?
At this point, does it matter
to delineate that any further?
- Yeah, it does matter.
So the word woke, there
were, a month or two ago,
there was debates.
It crossed over from
conservative media
to liberal media
about what the word woke means.
What's the definition
of the word woke?
What does this mean? And
it's a great question.
It's a question we
should all be asking.
So I actually traced
back the word woke.
- Can I do mine in two?
Can I do mine in two sentences
and you tell me if I'm doing
it all right 'cause everybody
was asking, can I do mine?
- Oh, yes, go ahead.
Lay it on me.
- It's believing in
equity over equality
with a dash of racism
and a little gender
confusion. How's that?
- That's exactly how it's
manifested and applied.
The ideology underneath
it can be traced directly
to a Brazilian Marxist
named Paolo Freire.
Paolo Freire applied this
idea to the education system,
in Brazil, he actually
experimented on
peasants in Brazil.
He ran these like 45-day
experiments on peasants
teaching them only
leftist things in school
so that they would then go out
and vote for
leftist politicians.
And he said that, "Teaching
knowledge in school
was oppressive."
He said, "Knowledge, there's
no such thing as knowledge.
There's no such thing as
truth or objective reality."
It's just, he said, he
defined knowledge and fact
as just the prevailing
political ideology, right?
He said, "Children instead
of being taught knowledge
should be taught
critical consciousness,"
which is a way of
thinking about the world.
Now, critical consciousness is
just a euphemism for teaching
children to view everything
through the lens of Marxism.
That's what wokeness is.
Wokeness is just a
rebranding of Freire's
critical consciousness.
So if you look at
wokeness in our country,
whether it's corporations,
whether it's in the classroom,
whether it's DEI, whether
it's gender ideology,
it's all Freire's
critical consciousness.
It's training this young
generation of American children
to view everything
through the Marxist lens
of oppressor versus oppressed.
That the oppressed have to
revolt against the oppressors,
overthrow the
civil institutions.
For what purpose?
For the purpose that Marxists
have laid out from the very
beginning, to overthrow
Western civilization.
- As evil as you think
the ideology obviously is.
are you ever impressed with
their ability to have had it
spread and how quickly
it's destroyed so much?
And also, how no
matter what happens,
it always causes
them to double down?
So, you know, for example,
if we reverse systemic racism
through the Supreme Court
getting rid of
affirmative action,
somehow now that
actually is proof to them
that the courts are corrupt,
thus more fuel for their fire.
- Listen, you know
what impresses me
and what, I actually paused
when I was writing this book
because it like hit
me as a revelation.
It impresses me that the
Democratic party today always
operates as a cohesive unit.
Like they never have any
significant dissenters.
Like it's they're always
are marching in lockstep.
And you compare that
to Republicans in
Congress or in the
Senate, and Republicans
seem kind of haphazard.
They're not always cohesive.
They can't always
like move as a unit.
And sometimes
Conservatives are like,
"Oh, that's because we allow
independent thinkers in the
Republican party."
That's not actually
why Republicans
don't operate in lockstep.
It's because Democrats are
committed to their ideology.
They know what their
ultimate goal is,
and they know the tools
that they're using
to achieve their ultimate goal.
But Republicans have lost sight
of what our ultimate goal is.
If you ask any Republican
in elected office,
any Republican commentator,
a Republican voter,
what is the ultimate
goal of our society?
What do we hope to
achieve with our society?
Most of them can't
answer what that is.
They can't answer,
"Well, is freedom the
means to something greater?
Or is freedom the ultimate end?"
Because those two things
are radically different
and radically change what
our governing philosophy
is at the State level
and the Federal level.
And if we don't as Republicans
have a cohesive definition
of what we want for our society,
then of course we're
not going to agree
on how we achieve that.
And then we're just gonna be
a chaotic party like we are.
And what happens when
we have a chaotic party?
It leads us to the cultural
crisis that we're in right now.
- Yeah, do you sense
some of that shifting
with the Republicans at all?
- I sense a new, and I
find, delightful tension
in the Republican party where
some people are waking up
to the fact that the old
guard of Republicanism
isn't effective.
I think a lot of
people don't know why
the old guard isn't effective.
We oftentimes ascribe it
to just being corrupt.
And don't get me wrong,
there's plenty of
corruption in politics,
even on the Republican side,
but it's not just corruption.
It is the lack of
ability to define
that the goal of a society
should be human flourishing.
We want human
beings to flourish.
That's what we want
from a society.
That's the goal of the
United States of America.
Our experiment in liberty,
the goal is human flourishing.
Maybe we define human
flourishing differently
than the Left does, which just
begets another conversation.
How are we going to define
what's the base level here?
The reality that we will all
agree on to build our society
off of, towards
something, towards what?
what are we going
to order it for?
What's the purpose of liberty?
And I'll give you a
concrete example here.
So David French,
we all know him.
He was at "The National Review,"
he's now in "The
New York Times."
He now writes for
"The New York Times."
He made an argument once
that "Drag Queen Story Hours"
where grown men dressing as
sexualized, stereotypical
versions of women, gyrate
in front of children
in scanty outfits.
It's horrendous.
He once made the argument that
that was one of the blessings
of liberty guaranteed
in our constitution.
(David laughs)
And I actually think that
this is a perfect example of a
disordered view on whether
liberty should be the means
to something greater or
whether liberty is the end
in and of itself.
If you define liberty
as the ultimate goal,
then yes, David
French is correct
because just the liberty
to do something like that,
even if you and I find
it to be horrendous,
would be moral because they
have the liberty to do that.
But we understand,
everyone understands,
that this is not a moral thing.
This is an abjectly
immoral thing for men
to act in that sexual
manner around children.
It's horrendous.
We all know this at a gut
level, a visceral level,
which should bring us
to the question, okay,
well, if liberty is
not the ultimate end,
then what is the ultimate end?
Is liberty, but the means
to something greater?
And if so, we should pass laws
and order our society
from the local, State,
and Federal level,
our institutions
such as the education system
and our religious institutions
towards that which liberty
allows us to achieve.
- So would you say that our
institutions can actually be
reverted back to something
more sane or can change at all?
Or do you think they
all need to be blown up?
Or maybe it's case by case
depending on religious
institution versus
governmental, et cetera?
- Both.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Both. I mean, there are
obvious examples of institutions
that should just be
razed and rebuilt
in some form like the
F B I or, you know,
the Department of Justice or
the public school system that
have just been captured
beyond recognizable,
beyond what is recognizable.
They've been completely
hijacked and weaponized
and are being used for evil,
and they should be abolished.
They should, they should,
we should get rid of them
and we can then discuss
what comes next.
But we can recapture
our institutions.
It's possible.
It's not easy.
And I don't wanna be one of
those Republicans that says,
"Oh, you know what,
if you just pray a lot
or if you just make good
decisions in your personal life,
that will have a trickle-down
effect to politics."
I'm not degrading
either of those things.
I'm a devout Christian,
I pray every day.
I try to order my personal
life and my family life
towards what I think is
good and right and beautiful
and just, but that's not enough.
Conservatives have fallen for
this idea that government in
and of itself is bad
and therefore any
use of government is
somehow tinged
with stigma, right?
That only Liberals
use government to
achieve their ends.
This is not true.
This is not how our
constitution was set up.
We actually have a
responsibility and a duty to use
government to properly
order our society towards,
I would argue that freedom
is a means to justice.
We should use our government
to order our society towards
true justice.
In fact, I don't
believe in neutrality
so I don't believe that if
we withdraw from governments
because we don't want the
stigma of using government
to achieve our ends,
I don't believe that we can
keep a neutral playing field.
Either the left is going to
occupy it or we are going to
occupy it.
Right now the left
is, but we can,
there's nothing holding
us back except ourselves.
- Would you say the best current
example of that is what's
gone on with Disney over
the past year where DeSantis
actively decided to
fight the culture war
and then suddenly
Republicans like Mike Pence,
like Chris Christie,
like Nikki Haley, all
were suddenly saying,
"Whoa, whoa, this isn't
what we use government for."
And it's like, if that's not
what you use government for
to get rid of crony capitalism,
to save our children,
et cetera, et cetera,
then I don't know.
Then I guess you're all
anarchists more than let's say
Republicans or Conservatives,
I guess would be your point.
- Yes, that's a perfect example.
That's a perfect example.
DeSantis, Governor DeSantis,
used his just power
as governor to order
society, to hold accountable
an organization that
had special privileges
from the government when
it benefited the people
of the state and revoking
those special privileges
when that entity no longer
benefited the state.
He had an absolute
right to do that,
it's not even controversial.
Another good example
is the bills in states
across the country.
Some of them are laws, they're
basically in litigation
right now on whether states
can prohibit transgender
surgeries for minors.
You have a lot of Republican,
even candidates for president,
I think Chris Christie
and Asa Hutchinson
both said, you know,
"That's not the role of
the government to ban that,
that should be a
parent's decision."
And my response to that is,
you don't understand
reality here.
We already use government to
prohibit parents from abusing
their children, right?
You're not allowed to physically
or verbally abuse your
child as that's correct.
That's exactly what the
government should do,
is prevent that type of abuse.
And we use it culturally
and societally too.
A child, for example,
is not allowed to go in
onto the floor of a casino. Why?
Because as a society,
we agree that that
is not a moral thing,
a proper thing for
a child to be doing.
A child's not allowed to go
into an establishment that
primarily serves alcohol.
We already use
the government to,
not to supersede
parental rights,
I'm all about parental rights,
but to protect
children from abuse,
to protect children
from abject immorality.
If it is not the role of the
government to protect these
young children
from exploitation,
from pharmaceuticals
and cross-ex hormones
and surgery that
will ruin their bodies for
life, then, my goodness,
what is the purpose
of government?
Like, why do we even bother?
- How much of the
stuff related to kids,
as you mentioned, you have
a two-and-a-half year old,
you've given us a
lot of sage wisdom
as new fathers over here.
But being a new mother,
how much of that affected how
clearly passionately you feel
about all of this
and what do you think
you'll do going forward
in terms of schooling
and all of that?
Because these are decisions
I'm gonna have to make as well
soon enough.
- Yeah, definitely.
And just for everyone watching,
you should know that the
majority of our texting threads
are like crunchy
parenting advice being
sent back and forth.
It's a constant.
No, it's already impacted
my decisions about
how my husband and I
have begun to raise
our two-and-a-half year old.
We don't defer to the experts,
you know that I'm kind
of anti pediatrician
because I don't
trust pediatricians
who are beholden to the
American Academy of Pediatrics.
If they don't operate
by the standards of care
that the American Academy
of Pediatrics lays out,
then they can be held
legally accountable
or they're liable legally.
And so they don't give
their best judgment.
They just say what the AAP says.
The AAP like recommends
transgender surgeries for kids
and talks about DEI
and that's not even
taking into consideration
the big pharma corruption
with this 74 vaccine
schedule for children
and the questionable efficacy
and safety of that vaccine
and the fact that you're
not allowed as a parent
to question it.
I mean, it's already impacted
how we raise our daughter.
- You're not even allowed to
question the schedule, right?
I mean, it's one thing
to question the vaccine,
they don't even want you
questioning the schedule.
I had RFK Junior on last week.
That's what we were discussing.
- Yeah, I had to fire
my first pediatrician
that I had for my daughter
because he was just giving me
the business about
questioning or spacing
or doing anything that differed
just slightly from the CDC
and the AAPs
recommended schedule.
And I'm like, I'm
not about this.
Like I'm the parent here.
I don't wanna co-parent
with the government.
I don't wanna co-parent with
a corrupted institution.
Going forward, I
mean, we're planning,
she's only two-and-a-half
so she has a few years,
but we're planning
to homeschool.
There's no way that
I'm gonna send my child
to a public school,
no way in this world.
I think one of the interesting
things to observe is in the
past couple years
since Covid really,
a lot of people, and this,
I don't wanna tell
tales on my husband,
but my husband is
included in this category,
didn't believe that some of
this radical gender ideology
was in their local
public school, right?
Like you believed that
it was in California,
you might've believed
it was in New York.
You believed in an
isolated incident
that you read on the
news here or there,
but you didn't believe
that it was everywhere,
that it could be in
your own neighborhood,
in front of your own child.
And I think parents have really
been awakened to the fact
that this capture of our
education system is complete,
this capture of our education
institution is total,
and that your child will
not be able to avoid it.
You can't opt them out of
social emotional learning.
It's too integrated into
everything about schools
and social emotional learning,
a lot of parents
know what this is
and they find it
to be questionable.
I talk about this in my book
because social emotional
learning is another name
for the critical consciousness
that Paulo Freire,
the Brazilian Marxist,
wanted every child to
be brainwashed with.
It's disguised as,
"Oh, this is how we
teach children values.
This is how we
teach them morals.
teach them to behave
in a manner that reflects
right and wrong."
But we should all be asking,
"Well, what is your
definition of right and wrong?
What is your
definition of a value?"
And if you dig into that
social emotional learning,
which is in every public school,
most of the private
schools too in our country,
it's just Marxism.
It is a Marxist worldview.
It's critical consciousness,
it's wokeness,
whatever term you want
to use to describe it
and I cannot expose
my child to that.
So I'm sitting here waiting
for the Hillsdale homeschool
curriculum to drop, hint, hint,
anybody at Hillsdale
who's listening,
but no, we're going
to homeschool.
- Listen, I can't say too much,
but I know that a couple people
in Florida are working on a
couple solutions to this stuff
that might work out because,
you know, you've got a
two-and-a-half-year old,
so there's a little
time to play with there.
I think a lot of people are
sort of onboard this idea that
the secular institutions
have failed,
but maybe they're not
quite realizing how badly
the religious institutions
have also failed.
And I would say that probably
goes across virtually
all of the religious
institutions in the country,
regardless of denomination.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
- Yeah, it's quite sad.
I'm a devout Catholic.
I'm a practicing Christian.
And it was quite sad
doing the research
for this part of my book
because I looked at some
of the surveys about
not just religious
participation, like
attendance of church,
that's obviously down and
it's been trending down
for a long time but if
you look at what people
actually believe, there's
only only three out of 10
young Americans, this is
Gen Z and millennials,
if millennials can
still be termed young,
and as a millennial, I
still claim that term,
only three out of 10 believe
in the God of the Bible.
That means that the overwhelming
majority of young people
in America don't believe
in anything greater,
in anything bigger, in God,
in that aspect of reality.
And it explains somewhat why
there's so much confusion about
terms like justice and right
and wrong and morality and
empathy and love and
compassion and tolerance
because if you don't have some
kind of fundamental belief,
then you're, everything
emanates out of that, right?
Like even in our
society right now,
we have laws against homicide,
we have laws against assault,
we have laws against rape.
Why do we have these laws?
Why do we have them?
Why are these laws different
for human beings than they are
for dogs or horses?
Because at the base level,
whether you are a practicing
religious person or not,
our countries foundation
acknowledges that
human beings are
made in the image
and likeness of God,
and as such should be
treated with dignity.
We recognize, our
constitution recognizes,
the definition of
what justice is.
So not to get too nerdy
and historical here,
but if freedom is
not the ultimate end,
if freedom is the means
to something greater,
we should ask the
question, well,
what is the something
greater? What is it?
Well, our founding fathers,
the framers of our constitutions
actually defined what it is
that our society
should be ordered to.
And what it is is justice.
James Madison said
in Federalist 51
that "The definition
of liberty is justice,"
but what is justice?
The framers of our
constitution define that along
Judeo-Christian terms that
the definition of justice
was God's original justice.
Again, you don't have to be a
practicing religious person.
This is not a theocracy,
but there is a necessity
for some kind of agreement
on what these words mean
or else you're going
to beget chaos.
And I don't need to
describe for everyone
that we are currently
living in this chaos.
- Right, so I think most
people watching this
agree with that for sure.
What would you say has to
happen to the institutions?
I mean, for the
church, for example,
since that's your
denomination, I mean,
what do you think
actually has to happen?
- Well, I think the church,
the Catholic church,
I'll speak to personally because
I'm a practicing Catholic,
the Catholic church
has been extremely lax
in their catechesis,
which means the teaching of
the faith to the faithful.
They have not
explained and defended
the tenets of the faith.
And when you don't have a
good grasp of what you believe
and why you believe it, you
are very vulnerable to that
which you think you believe
being twisted by someone else.
So, for example, we're told
by AOC that the Green New deal
is environmental justice.
We're told by Planned Parenthood
that abortion is
reproductive justice.
If you don't have a
good understanding
about what justice means based
on your religious belief,
then you're going to
be very vulnerable
to falling for people
that are lying to you,
people that are false prophets.
So first of all,
the church needs to be very
clear about their responsibility
and their duty to
catechize their faithful.
If we did this in a better way,
if we did this in a
more effective way,
then we would have more cultural
warriors like you and I,
who are unafraid to stand
up against the Marxists
assaulting our institutions.
The church actually,
and I know this is
getting really nerdy,
but this is the part of my book
that might be my favorite part,
the Catholic church
as an institution,
has been one of the
strongest bulwarks
against communism and
Marxism and socialism
in the modern world.
The popes, especially like
around the time of Marx
and Engels, when they were
writing the Communist Manifesto
around the time of
the Soviet Union,
it was Catholic popes
who were saying,
"Listen, communism is satanic,
this is not just a
political battle,
not just a secular battle,
not just an economic battle.
This is a battle of
good versus evil,
that communism comes from the
devil and that no Christian
should or can be
both a Christian
and a communist
Marxist or socialist."
They have fought at
the institutional level
from the beginning of this,
from the beginning of communism
and Marxism against it,
but recently they've
lost their way.
Recently they've become
a little less based
and a little more
squishy, not doctrinally,
but in their communication,
in their willingness
to fight back.
So I, of course, I
mean, you know me,
I have strong opinions.
I'm not afraid of, I
guess, confrontation.
I don't wanna think of myself
as a confrontational person,
but it's necessary sometimes
to challenge what is wrong,
even if it's uncomfortable.
And I feel like this is true
for evangelical churches and
Protestant churches as well
as the Catholic church.
They've forgotten that
sometimes love is, you know,
Jesus flipping tables.
It's not always, let me
just scratch your back
and pat your head and tell
you that you're pretty.
And if we get back to the
true definition of love
and compassion and justice,
then it's going to equip a
whole generation of people
to fight back against
essentially the antichrist,
the antichrist of communism.
- How worried are you that
the machines, that AI,
the algorithms, big tech,
that they will put
their foot on the scale?
They obviously
have been already,
but if we were just having
an ideological battle,
Marxism verse say, capitalism
or freedom, you know,
individualism
verse collectivism,
if we were just battling
that out, I think we win.
I think the human spirit
wins and all that.
But now on that
scale also comes AI,
also comes manipulated
information,
also comes search engines
that will tell you
the reverse of the truth
when you search certain things,
that makes this battle
much more difficult.
- It does, it does.
So AI, I think a lot
of people mistake AI.
AI is not like an
autonomous entity.
It's not like a sentient being.
AI is an algorithm.
It's a piece of code that
was written by somebody,
and that somebody or somebodies
are very politically-biased
people who have an agenda.
All you have to do
is go into ChatGBT.
I actually did this this
weekend, this past weekend.
I spoke at the Young Americas
Foundation conference,
and beforehand, I asked
ChatGPT to write me a poem
on the dangers of the
transgender ideology and ChatGPT
told me that it was
discriminatory and hateful
and that they couldn't do it.
So then I asked ChatGPT
to write me a poem
about the dangers
of the gender binary
and it did write a poem
about the dangers of
the gender binary.
So you can see the obvious
bias inherent to these systems,
and the biggest danger of
them all is manipulation.
It's manipulating people.
It's disguising the truth
and instead redefining words
so that people
accidentally or unknowingly
fall for your ideology,
meaning the Marxist ideology.
I agree with you.
On a level playing field,
capitalism would defeat
communism every time.
But that's why the Marxists
are targeting our children
because they know if they
wait till they're adults
and they allow them
to experience reality,
no one's ever gonna
choose to be a communist.
But if they can
indoctrinate them,
if they can erase
or twist and warp,
pollute the natural law
that exists within all of us
as our conscience,
as our reason,
then they will be able
to convince these people,
these young children,
who in 10 years
won't be children anymore, to
be Marxists, to be communists.
That's why they're
attacking our kids.
- So all that being
said, are you hopeful
that we can actually turn
this thing around, I mean,
a whole bunch of us can
try to red-pill people,
we can try to, you know,
get some more based people
out there and sensible
people and all that.
But it does seem
like we still lose
a lot of the mini battles.
We win little ones like Disney
or maybe that's a big one,
but overall, the tendency,
especially if you look
at the polling of young people
thinking socialism is cool,
like it does seem to
be going the wrong way.
- Well, listen, I
wouldn't be sitting here
if I thought it was
a losing battle.
That'd be too depressing.
I wouldn't fight this
battle if I thought
it was already lost.
So my presence in this
battlefield is an indication
that I think that we can win.
You have to remember that
this is not something that
happened overnight.
It's not something that
happened since Obama took office
or since Biden took
office or, you know,
during the Trump years.
This is an assault
on our institutions
that's been going on
for almost a century,
a century, 100 years.
Conservatives
didn't recognize it.
We were so drunk with our own
prosperity in our nation that
we just sat by and didn't
recognize the spiritual battle,
good versus evil, that
was raging around us
as these Marxists went
into our education systems.
First, you know, Ivy
League teachers colleges,
and disseminated this poison
into all of these institutions.
I mean, into even the
administrative state, right?
Dr. Fauci being like, "You
listen to me, I'm an expert."
That he's acting
as a technocrat.
- I am the science.
- We all use the
word technocrat.
I am the science, and you
shouldn't criticize it.
"I worry if I'm
criticized," Fauci says,
but what he's doing is he's
acting as a technocrat.
We use that term
but what we should do
when we say that term is
we shouldn't just say, "Oh
yeah, he's a technocrat
That's an insult, that's a
bad thing," is we should say,
"What is a technocrat?
What is technocracy?"
It's ruled by the experts.
But I trace this back
actually in my book
to the origin of technocracy.
The origin of technocracy,
one of the founders
of technocracy was
a Russian scientist
who admitted in his writings
that technocracy is nothing but
a stepping stone from
capitalism to communism.
It's how you trick people
in a capitalist society
to transform themselves
into a communist society,
So yes, we can undo this.
This first step to undoing
it is recognizing and
acknowledging the reality of
the political enemy we face,
understanding all
of this ideology and
the people behind it.
And the second part
is not quite as easy.
I'm not gonna pretend to
be one of those Republicans
that's just like Paul Ryan.
"If we get our fiscal
house in order,
everything will follow."
(David laughs)
Or if you just mind your own
business in your own house,
everything will, it'll
be a downstream effect.
No, we have to be comfortable
as a Republican party
using the government
to ban DEI, to ban ESG,
to ban transgender
surgeries for children.
We have to abolish the
administrative state.
We have to actively, once
we flag defense in that way,
we have to play offense.
We have to mandate that
children in public schools
are taught about the
horrors of communism.
That they are taught
the science of sex.
And I'm not talking about
sex like reproduction.
I'm talking about, I don't
wanna use the word gender
because it's been co-opted-
- Biological reality.
- But taught about
biology and DNA.
- Yeah,
- The biological reality
of male and female.
We have to be able and
willing and understand
that this is our heritage,
our constitutional heritage
is a heritage of ordered
liberty, not this
absolute liberty.
I don't even wanna
call it libertarianism
because it kind of is,
but it's a little bit
further than libertarianism
where it's ultimately just
gonna turn into social anarchy
if we embrace that, even if
it sounds cool on its surface,
we have to be cohesive as
a Republican party and use
government where we have
the just authority to do so.
It's not easy, but
it can be done.
- You're basically saying
by day three in Burning Man,
it's time to, you know, go home.
I think something like that.
- Yes, what I wrote in my
book is I was like, listen,
the first half of this book
can be somewhat depressing.
Not that you should come
away from it depressed,
but like it's heavy stuff to
realize exactly how the left
this huge plot behind, I mean,
we talk often about George Soros
and how he's behind
so many things.
I don't talk about Soros
as much in this book
because some of the institutions
and people behind the
attack on our nation's kids
and on our institutions
take the form
of these shadowy,
complicatedly-named groups
and institutions.
But what they're propagating
is the ideology of Marxism.
So what I want people
to come away with
after they read this book
is a thorough understanding
of the ideology so
that you can look
at social emotional learning.
You can look at teaching
for social justice.
You can look at technocracy and
you can say, "Wait a second,
I recognize that, I recognize
the elements of Marxism
inherent to that,
and it gives me strength
and the capacity
to utterly reject it."
So the first half may be heavy,
but the second
half, like, listen,
you are gonna come out swinging
after you put this book down
because it is, my
editor actually told me
that the last chapter
was intimidating
for a president of
the United States,
let alone a flustered parent.
And I was like, "Thank you.
I take that as a compliment."
That's what the
Republican party needs.
We don't need soft
establishment leadership.
We need someone that's like,
it's not gonna be easy,
but if you actually wanna win,
here's a blueprint
for how to do it.
- Liz, as I always say to you,
but how do you really feel?
If I could only figure it out,
if you could just be a little
clearer in your language
and tell me how you really feel.
We are gonna link to
the book down below.
It was a pleasure to
see you, my friend,
and I will text you some
children questions after this.
- Thank you, Dave.
I really appreciate it.
Everyone just go to
Amazon or wherever
you wanna buy your books
if you hate Jeff Bezos,
and make sure you subscribe-
- Right down below.
- to "The Liz Wheeler
Show" on Apple Podcasts.
Right down below.
Thanks, Dave.
- She's a podcast pro,
all right, thanks, Liz.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.